[Applause]
celebrations across tegucigalpa as
ciumara castro a former first lady of
honduras was sworn in to become the
country's first female president
dear sisters and brothers honduran
people the presidency of the republic
had never been assumed by a woman in
honduras
200 years have had to pass since the
declaration of our independence
city streets throughout the capital
tegucigalpa closed for a parade to
celebrate the historic inauguration many
expressed their hopes the country may
finally turn a page after more than a
decade of single party rule marred by
scandal and political turmoil that have
fueled a historic wave of migration
we hope that she will deliver that which
we've been hoping for for years
that people will no longer migrate to
other countries that people will stay
and have decent employment because we
all have a right to that and it's what a
majority of the people expect to stay in
their country nobody wants to be away
from their home and that is what she
will accomplish
dozens of high-profile guests were also
in attendance including u.s vice
president kamala harris who seeks to
strengthen a bilateral partnership with
honduras to address the root causes of
migration from central america
poverty has increased by 74
to turn our country into the poorest in
latin america this statistic in itself
explains the caravans of thousands of
people who flee north towards mexico and
the united states
while the lord here in the capital city
is that of celebration inauguration day
is taking place under a backdrop of a
political crisis in the honduran
national congress
legislators however appear to have at
least temporarily put aside the
political standoff to allow citizens to
celebrate the peaceful transfer of power
president
castro ran on an anti-corruption
platform promising an overhaul of the
country's legal system her ability to
govern effectively however will
ultimately depend on finding common
ground with her political opponents in
the honduran legislature
manuel rapalo al jazeera tegucigalpa